hello good afternoon and welcome to the
after craft award sessions thank you
very much for being with us we are
absolutely delighted to welcome one of
our production design nominees for craft
Awards grant Montgomery grant has been a
production designer on productions
including Jamaica wren birdsong and the
Crimson petal in the white for which he
received the production design RTS award
in 2011 and the judges said of the
program it simply took you to another
world with its stunning imagery of
Victorian life nothing was sacrificed
transferring this novel to the small
screen grant has nominated for these
awards for his work on peaky blinders
it would be great just to get a little
bit of background from you on how you
what drew you to production design in
the first place and how you knew this
would be the thing for you to do with
your life um it was I mistaken to
Pinewood when I was like about 1213 and
to see the deceitful of me
and the big kind of eternal of the the
be can Adam said that was on that at
that point was the ss7 stage and it was
the tank of internal the time I went in
there and I was like wow wow that's an
incredible set and it was just I just
amazing so it was kind of from there on
in and it was just a love of watching
movies my my mother used to take me to
madness and sort of like I watch things
like Cromwell and Oliver Twist and it
was just that and it was just it just
grew from there
I saw what really that's why we wanted
to do she was very from very early age
well I didn't really have any kind of
focus anywhere else it was kind of that
was go of what gonna do but then I
studied theater design because there
wasn't really at that point any this
when I was when I went on to do a degree
it was not there wasn't that many film
courses around and so it was theater so
I went to Nottingham Trent and did
theatre but I had no intentions of doing
theater it was just I'll just do theater
but I'll do it like I was gonna make any
TV or film that was kind of what I was
really into so the sets tended to be a
bit more cinematic than they were a kind
of theater sets and so that was really
where I came from
so aliases of I graduated I was offered
a kind of holiday relief at that point
which was the BBC did or designer
designer system and you flung in doing
all sorts of things you shouldn't have
been doing really so that's how it
started so we're going to focus
initially if you on your work on peaky
blinders
it's an extraordinary world and one that
has changed over the course of the
seasons and that that change has been a
part driven
with the with the production design
it feels a bit like history and of want
it to have been I don't know you know I
don't know that really ever since I
really know I don't you know again the
club's quite important because that's
the only time you ever see London in the
whole series so I was really I was
really pushing to say good look if you
got Birmingham you've made berming quite
big how are you gonna make the
metropolis even bigger and more decadent
and Steven has gone on record as saying
is is he said that the drug in the
second series is cocaine so you know you
think I'm gonna go do a whole club
that's kind of you know sort of like on
cocaine and so I've really upped the
ante on the gold so you've got antique
gold in the first series and then you go
even warmer Gold's in the second but it
was so that second season said that
there's a continuation of tone and so
walking into the club into that location
which we found in Liverpool it was a
huge white ceiling and I remember
looking at it and I said to the producer
I don't paint that gold and I think he
went really pale as if how much is that
gonna cost me and I think it's mentioned
earlier I think was about 58 gallons of
gold paint and they returned it peaky
gold so you can buy it now from whoever
makes it and we painted it all gold I
think the painters came came out and I
go
we basically transfer transformed all
the world's futures everything's great
because you had to make it
you had to make it what Tommy wanted
when you're moving then sir you've got
serious one which is very Western
influence series - which is much more
gangsta influence but obviously it's the
same story world it's the same
characters how do you make sure that you
know you're not changing the identity so
dramatically that you lose an audience
the wave I thought was that progress was
that space it became bigger I've kind of
quite interesting the way that sort of
money buys bigger spaces and Tommy's
world's growing so when you go in for
example - what you're the betting that
the industry is that they've knocked
down three or four other houses they've
move the occupants out and it's grown
bigger so the size of it is so you get
that sense you've kept the same textures
but the space has become larger
just like his office is larger and that
the nightclubs are larger so you keep
the tones deep and the fabric but every
the spaces have become larger because
he's been buying London houses he's he's
got a plan and he's using he's using his
money in a very specific way so the
space will become larger and obviously
not everything ends up on camera that's
right it has to be heartbreaking yes
sometimes it is well cuz that was it
yeah absolutely but you've got but I
never was more interested in the story
yeah I don't really get that disappoint
I'm more interested in that you know
what the directors done and the DOP is
done and as in the actors you're in a
collaborative art form in its I loved it
the surprise when I sit down and watch
and if you've made that contribution to
the overall story that's that's that's
exciting I don't ever really kind of
think they should have shown that but
wider or whatever I don't don't kind of
don't get hung up on those sort of
things
I mean you have any kind of do you have
any tips for I suppose production
designers or only career production
designers who want to understand how
production design can lead or inform
story
I've just you know I I'm you know it's
like wasn't it that that that great line
that so when awesome elves asked if you
studied victory the old masters yeah
John Ford John Ford John Ford I think
you've got to go back and study some of
the great designers I'm a big Africa of
of you know going back and looking at
Kennedy you know Ken Adams work or Doug
Stewart quote but even further back like
William Cameron Menzies I mean when
Cameron Menzies is that the granddaddy
as far as I'm concerned I can do I
probably about bashed a drum for all
those Golden Age designed uh selectively
you watch them that they're every
technique every the story the way they
tell stories through images is great
sort of they're they interest me and I
think you should be going back and
looking at that because that's where the
art form originated so you should be
going like painters you should go back
and I would always say that I've said
that one when I've gone to colleges you
go and look at these guys they're still
there go there they're workers there to
be studied you know I love those big
kind of sixties huge tentacle of movies
and sort of Kafani oh and John war and
all those how did they do that you know
the risks they took wow that's I mean to
put just what you know I'm amazed always
by the with the way in which you know
you can put just one prop and they can
tell a story so I'm really into that so
that's why I would say go and study all
of those absolutely keep studying keep
looking mm-hmm um we have a little type
of questions I mean starting outs always
hard and everybody starts somewhere
whether it's art background architecture
theater school whatever um
and everybody has such a different
trajectory and obviously that the number
one thing is passion in my opinion you
don't have a passion for it but then you
know how
what's your I mean you started out one
day and you had to approach production
designers and it's all about
personalities and the right fit isn't it
with a lot of art departments
I mean do you have any good advice on
how to approach some people that
sometimes you know you might be
intimidated by or you know you've come
from a very different background like
how what's your advice on how to
approach certainty but you know I
remember I remember contacting when I
was kind of like Elliott Scott or anyone
knows how it's got to play Indiana Jones
films
I wasn't petrified when I went to see
him and sort of and but I kind of always
wished I've asked him for a picture
though because he was in I was in his
study I wish had to ask for one actually
but I didn't really have the courage to
do that but I think you just have to be
passionate about it just I think also
having a knowledge of that person's work
whoever they are I think that's really
really important because why are you
going to meet them I think if you if
that communicates itself to the person
then you're going to have a better
chance of connecting in some way if you
say I love what you did the girl or that
person you know because I love this work
or all the designers I approach you know
I when I was coming I just want the I
was how he did what you know that was
fantastic I loved so it was more kind of
I think you have to just be passionate
about it if it's it's amazing sort of
like you because you've got to be
passionate you're gonna get up at 5:30 6
o'clock in the morning to go out and do
something so when you're meeting
somebody B I think we just having that
passion about what they do it connects
with what you do that was absolutely
fascinating
I wish we could talk for another
ah-ha-ha-ha unfortunately we've got to
wind it up thank you so much for coming
thank you so much for joining us and
sharing so generously your experience
and your knowledge good luck tomorrow
thank you Thanks
you
you